Nói 9,8 hành ra 20,5, thông tin từ công an tình lạ sân.
Đơn vị đã ra quy định hợi tổ bi cân và lệ bắt bị cân để tạm ra bởi đận và sáng,
sinh 1,7,5, chú phương tâm thành, tình lạ sân, nguyên là phó đội trưởng đổi quả lý thị trường số bốn, tình lạ sân, về tội dịch nổi.
Trước đó, công an tình lạ sân và hiện trên các nền tạng mạng xác hội xuất hiện hình ảnh, video một tả vụ việc có giữ vấn dịch nổi vây hóa mạng dưới lợi.
Quả có chiến điều tra, sóc mình, tài liệu chính cứ tu thập được, công an tình lạ sân xác định là nguyên xân đặt,
sinh 1,9,7, chú tài xác tình hân, tình hương ín, đối tượng thực hiện hình viết người là đoàn và sáng.
Quả năng hành ủ trăm hai môi, sáng quên đặt quan hình tạng mạng xác hội,
bảo mề hành lạm thẳng 1 năm hành ủ trăm hai mạng, sáng đá hỏa để thoại và thống nước với đặt để đặt đến nơi làm việc của sáng.
Tại đây, sáng đá thực hiện hình viết giết đặt, sau khi về an, sáng có nhiều hình viết tầy, soa zâu vết,
phía trang phía thiện nhằm một đích chế dấu hành viết phạm tội, đối phó với các quan chức năng.
Nghe hành ạm thẳng 1 năm hành ủ trăm hai mạng, các quan cạnh rất đều tra công an tình lạng sân đã ra quy định khởi tổ hủ an hình xử dưới.
Nghe hành ủ trăm hai mạng ủ trăm hai mạng, ra quy định khởi tổ bí cân và lựng bắt bị cân để tạm sáng đều với đàn và sáng về tổ dưới.
Hình công an tình lạng sân tiếp tục của hợp, chỉ đạo các lần bị linh quan quy định đấu trang,
chúi sét, mở dọc đưa trà, sử lý vụ an theo quy định.
Quà vụ việc này đến nghĩ người dân, đối không chia sẻ, bị lợt, lát chuyển các video, hình an tư cực,
kích đọc bạo lực lúc quan đến vụ an trên, mò hình viết chia sẻ, đăng tải,
trên bà chè phép các hình an, video nếu trên sẽ bị sử lý nghiêm theo quy định của pháp lật.
Nói dân cần nâm cao nhận tức khi thăm ra các hội nhóm, giết là các hội nhóm có dấu hiệu nghiệp vẫn vì pháp pháp lật trên khu zan mạc.
Khi tối chính báo của quán chức năng khi pháp hiện vụ việc dấu hiệu nghiệp vẫn, các hình vi lực trần bạo lực vì pháp pháp lật.